hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in chapter 29 of
the monologue handsome begins a line of
reasoning which is I'm going to focus
upon what he calls the divine lacoochee
o or expression or the divide word the
verbum and what he's going to be driving
in this is essentially in Christian
doctrine the second person of the
Trinity the son although he's not going
to call it as such yet he's going to
deal with that in later chapters he's
gradually working his way towards that
by looking at how the divine substance
is related to creation but also related
to itself and so there's going to be
some really interesting discussions of
expression and identity and utterance
and essence going on in these chapters
to come so he begins in chapter 27 by
talking about the utterance of low
Cuchillo the divine substance this is
something that we've already seen
discussed in previous chapters earlier
on and we've done some videos
specifically about that and he says that
this is
fact the same as the divine substance so
there's a difference right at least for
us in the way that we're normally
thinking about expression and some for
example expressed himself in the Mona
loggia I'm just you know holding a copy
of that here which is a copy of a copy
of a copy and we can go on and on from
from there we're used to thinking about
expression as being something different
from the thing expressing but but even
so we can think of some sorts of
expression where it is the thing itself
that's doing the expressing for instance
my facial expressions are expressions of
emotions for het perhaps that I feel
inside like anger or surprise or
whatever we want right there we we see
expression is being closed more closely
connected and remembering ana some
things that some of the ways in which we
express things some of the little couch
yet yeah well Cuchillo that we have are
in the inner mind you know we think in
terms of words of use or we we reason or
we imagine all those are examples of
expression or onerous in this case so
the audience of the divine substance he
asserts is going to be the same as the
divine substance right he wants to
examine this this utterance by which all
things were made how does he come to the
point in saying that it has to be the
same thing as what's doing the
expression that that is how does he come
to the point of saying the expression
has to be the same thing as the express
sir you might say so he says well if the
Supreme Spirit made nothing except
through itself and whatever was made by
the Supreme Spirit or the supreme
substance was made through its utterance
how can the utterance be anything other
than what he himself is and he says
consider further the utterance is not a
created thing because it was what
everything else was created through
right so it's not as if God first
created you know this utterance which
that it could use is kind of like a rule
or
a measure something like that it's
already there in God eternally says get
an someone's going to Seco eternally we
can't even say from the beginning just
it's just there right alright sort of
outside the bounds of time so it wasn't
a creative thing or it's not a great
thing it also wasn't made through itself
if we had that case not only does an
some say God doesn't make himself anyway
but then we would have the problem of
multiple divine beings who are self
creating and an some things that that's
just not going to work so instead on how
should we make sense of this he says
it's the understanding intelligentsia
and utterance of the Supreme Spirit the
divine substance he says it cannot be
understood as anything other than the
understanding of that spirit by which he
understands all things for what is it
for him to utter something and his sense
of uttering other than to understand it
unlike a human being he never fails to
utter what he understands so if this
supremely simple nature is nothing other
than what is understanding is because
remember anything that God is God is
entirely that so if God is understanding
God is totally understanding as well as
being reason wisdom goodness all the
other divine attributes he says just the
same as he is what is wisdom is that it
must be that in the same way he has
nothing other than what is under it says
but since it's already evident that the
Supreme Spirit is only one and in every
way individual his utterance fury Anselm
uses this term explicitly must be Co
substantial that is of the same
substance with him so that they're not
two spirits not two different beings but
one being which then you might say well
we have different what how do we want to
describe it that's what we're going to
get to a little bit later let's go on
and take a look at what else he has to
say chapter 30 he's considering the
question is this multiple words sort of
like a composite that's put together we
talking about the utterance or is it
just one single unified word one verbum
larry's using the word word explicitly
well why would we be tempted to think
that the word could be multiple or
Compeyson well the word is that through
which everything else all these creative
beings are indeed created according to
handsome and these are different beings
right this is not the same thing as this
or this so why shouldn't there be
different whatever we want to call them
expressions logos you know accounts
whatever of these different things why
should then the word be like a super
complex almost like a encyclopedia
through which everything else is made or
like the master pattern well then we
would lose the unity of the work
wouldn't we and ansel consumers that to
already been established so we're going
to have one word that is actually
supremely simple going beyond the
simplicity that we ourselves even work
with we've already seen that divining
simplicity is in some ways and make a
joke you're more complicated than what
we normally think of as simplicity so
let's go on then to the next chapter
chapter 31 Ansem does a lot of
interesting things to say here this is a
long chapter and I'm only going to hit
on certain parts of it that are relevant
here in chapter 31 he talks about he
says the words by which we say things in
our mind our likenesses and images of
the things of which their works right so
when when we imagine something the image
is the word in our mind and the real
thing is
what we're imagining even when we have
as Anselm says the the thing itself in
our mind like when we are understanding
rational animal as rational mortal
animal as human being in some studies
looked at still an image it's still not
the thing itself although that's that
one's more closely collect connected
because we're actually self reflecting
there but that's a topic we'll get to in
a minute so the question that is are the
things of creation like you and me and
everything else this chalkboard are they
what the word is an image of let's say
the word is totally perfectly simple you
know put that problem side are those
those things then the real things and
then the word is sort of like the
blueprint or the copy or the recording
or something along those lines Ansem
says no the priority of being is exactly
opposite things are in fact copies of
what they are in the word the reality of
them exists in this is this word and he
says the the word is the true and simple
and other point uses the term absolute
essence of the of which the created
beings are merely likenesses civil to
Denise or in my and my days they are
they're sort of knockoffs they're copies
there they're the extrapolations so even
the things that we take is being totally
real we say well these aren't imaginary
these aren't just you know you know
depicted or something like that they're
not as real as we as we think because
they're not as real as this true and
simple essence through which they are
what they are let's go on to the 32
which is where we're actually going to
take a sort of stopped in the argument
to another video specifically about some
of the aspects
this and the later chapters that come up
but we want to get you know at least to
the point of that we've got this issue
ok there's the Supreme Being the divine
substance the Supreme Spirit hoberg
wanna consider good and then it
expresses itself somehow in some word
that's supposed to be it at the same
time we've got two hands wrapped around
that what's going on with this it so it
creates created being through that but
what if it didn't create any created
being or what about before creation
happened does that mean the word didn't
exist at that time so we just had the
divine substance and then maybe you know
it starts expressing and boom there's
the world Anselm says no the Supreme
Spirit utters or understands itself
through the the word so it's it's not
merely a relation to external beings to
the created beings that are not the same
thing as the divine substance it is a
way in which the divine substance is
indeed totally related to itself not
just partially not just accidentally
totally related to itself so in finding
out about this word we're finding out
something that is integral to the divine
substance something that is of the very
nature and some insane to us of God so
it says if no essence other than the
Supreme Spirit ever existed according to
that the argument people would like to
make the no word at all would exist in
him if no word existed in him he would
not utter anything within himself now
for him to utter something is the same
to under this is to understand it so if
God were not to utter anything that
means that he would not be understanding
anything which means that the supreme
wisdom is he says which is nothing other
than that same spirit would not
understand anything so you might say
well what kind of supreme wisdom is that
you know you can say well you know it's
got the potential for understanding
things when maybe things
to show off but there's not anything
there to begin with so it's kind of
inactive dan seems to go against the
whole notion of you know wisdom itself
as being something that is better to be
then not to be so he says if nothing
existed apart from God what would he
understand so if God was going to
understand something and nothing had has
been created what is there to understand
God self understanding and this is where
we're getting to something really
interesting right the divine substance
would still express itself and
understand itself through the word he
says if we want to understand this we
can compare this to the human rational
mind which also likewise expresses
itself in relation to itself right when
you think of who you are or you ask
yourself did I understand everything
that's happening in this video let me
test my own knowledge there's a
referential T that's going on here it's
nothing quite like what what God thetac
is experiencing in the word but the word
itself this understanding is what what
God is similarly when you are reflecting
on your own rational mind Ansem says you
are using the rational mind to make a
sort of expression of itself which is
itself that just happens to be the case
even more for God or for the word so now
we have these two aspects remember a
handsome is asserting that these are not
distinct substances or distinct spirits
but they are things that we can
distinguish within the divine